>>> PROGRESSIVE CONGRESSMAN
RUBEN GALLEGO, SAYING, I KNOW
THEY'RE IN A DIFFICULT
SITUATION.
IF THE NEWLY INDEPENDENT KYRSTEN
SINEMA DECIDES TO RUN AGAIN,
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS WOULD BE
FORCED TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
STANDING BY GALLEGO, OR CINEMA.
LEADERS FROM BOTH PARTIES
ADDRESSING HIS RUN.
>> AS TO WHETHER OR NOT SHE
CHOOSES TO RUN AGAIN IS REALLY
HER DECISION, AND I THINK IT'S A
BIG DILEMMA FOR THE SENATE
DEMOCRATIC MAJORITY TO DECIDE
WHETHER TO SUPPORT HER OR TO
SUPPORT SOMEBODY RUNNING ON THE
DEMOCRATIC TICKET.
>> SENATOR SINEMA IS AN
EXCELLENT CONGRESS MEMBER AND
SENATE MEMBER AND SHE HAS DONE A
LOT OF GOOD THINGS HERE BUT IT'S
MUCH TOO EARLY TO MAKE A
DECISION.
>> JOINING ME NOW, DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN RUBEN GALLEGO OF
ARIZONA, THANK YOU, CONGRESSMAN.
I APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US.
WHY DO IT, WHY PUT YOUR PARTY
AND YOURSELF IN THIS POSITION?
>> WELL, IT'S NOT ABOUT MYSELF,
IT'S ABOUT THE PEOPLE OF
ARIZONA, AND THEY HAVE NOT
GOTTEN GOOD SERVICE FROM SENATOR
SINEMA.
>> WHY DO YOU BELIEVE, BECAUSE
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF CINCINNATI
DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE BEEN
RELUCTANT TO EMBRACE YOUR
CANDIDACY.
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT THAT?
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT THE
RELUCTANCE ON YOUR PARTY?
>> I HAVE TO FOCUS ON THE VOTERS
OF ARIZONA, THE PEOPLE I HAVE
KNOWN FOREVER AND HAVE WORKED
FOR, THE PEOPLE I WANT TO GO
TALK TO THIS WEEK STARTING IN
TUCSON, ENDING UP IN WHITE
RIVER, ARIZONA.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
MATTER.
>> YOU WOULD PREFER THAT THEY
SUPPORTED YOU?
>> OF COURSE, BUT LOOK, LET'S BE
HONEST.
IT'S A STICKY SITUATION.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF MEMBERS THAT
HAVE KNOWN EACH OTHER FOREVER,
IT'S AN INSIDER'S CLUB.
THEY DON'T WANT TO START MESSING
AROUND WITH THEIR FRIENDS.
WE HAVE TIME, AT THE END OF THE
DAY, WHAT MATTERS IS I'M GOING
TO WIN BECAUSE THE VOTERS OF
ARIZONA WANT ME.
>> HAVE YOU DISCUSSED YOUR
CANDIDACY WITH SCHUMER OR LARRY
PETERS, THEY RUN THE SENATE
DEMOCRATIC CAMPAIGN COMMITTEE.
WHAT DO THEY TELL YOU?
>> WE WILL ALWAYS HAVE OPEN
LINES OF COMMUNICATION.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THIS
CAMPAIGN, NOT AT THIS POINT.
WE ARE NOT AFRAID TO TALK TO
ANYBODY, AND WE'LL BE REACHING
OUT TO THEM AND REACHING OUT TO
ALL OTHER POLITICAL
ORGANIZATIONS SO THEY KNOW WHAT
A STRONG CAMPAIGN WE'RE RUNNING.
>> THE REASON I'M ASKING YOU
ABOUT THE CONCERNS FROM
DEMOCRATS IS BECAUSE THEY ARE
DEFENDING AT LEAST AS YOU KNOW,
23 SEATS IN 2024, AND ARIZONA
VOTERS ARE ALMOST EVENLY SPLIT
THREE WAYS BETWEEN DEMOCRATS,
REPUBLICANS, AND INDEPENDENTS.
AND I JUST WONDER, YOU KNOW,
THEY FAVOR MODERATE CANDIDATES,
BY THE WAY, COULD YOUR CANDIDACY
HAND THE SEAT TO THE GOP?
>> NO, ACTUALLY, MY CANDIDACY IS
PROBABLY THE ONLY THING THAT'S
GOING TO SAVE THE SEAT FROM THE
GOP.
KYRSTEN SINEMA CAN'T WIN ARIZONA
ANYMORE.
WHEN YOU SAY THE VOTES ARE SPLIT
IN A THIRD, SINEMA IS PULLING
14%.
SHE HAS LOST TRUST OF EVERYBODY,
AND WHEN'S THERE NO DEMOCRAT
RUNNING SHE'S LOSING TO
REPUBLICANS BY 5 POINTS.
IN D.C. LAND, AND LA LA LAND,
SHE'S NOT DOING WELL.
THERE'S A REASON I'M RUNNING.
THERE'S A REASON I HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO RAISE MORE THAN A
MILLION DOLLARS IN LESS THAN 24
HOURS, THROUGH 27,000 INDIVIDUAL
DONORS.
SHE'S NO LONGER POPULAR, AND
SHE'S GOING TO GIVE POWER BACK
TO REPUBLICANS BECAUSE SHE'S
UNPOPULAR WITH EVERYBODY IN
ARIZONA.
>> CAN WE PUT THE LAST GRAPHIC
UP, I WANT PEOPLE TO SEE THE
POLLING.
THERE IT IS.
SO AS AN INDEPENDENT, I THINK,
YOU KNOW, SHE IS FACING
POLITICAL HEAD WINDS, WHICH
CAUSED HER TO MAKE SOME OF HER
RECENT DECISIONS.
I'M WONDERING --
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
MARK KELLY DID NOT MAKE THOSE
RECENT DECISIONS.
MARK KELLY RAN AS A STRONG
DEMOCRAT AND MADE SOME, YOU
KNOW, GREAT DECISIONS, AND ENDED
UP HAVING ONE OF THE LARGEST
VICTORIES AS A SENATE CANDIDATE.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT HER.
NOT MARK KELLY.
SHE'S FACING POLITICAL HEAD
WINDS, IS WHAT I'M SAYING.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I APOLOGIZE.
YEAH, SHE'S RUNNING AS AN
INDEPENDENT BECAUSE SHE CAN'T
WIN A PRIMARY.
SHE'S NO LONGER POPULAR WITH
ANYBODY.
>> HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO HER?
>> NO, BUT DOESN'T REALLY
MATTER, BUT NOBODY IN ARIZONA
HAS SPOKEN TO HER IN THE LAST
FOUR YEARS.
THIS IS WHY SHE IS WHERE SHE IS.
SHE HASN'T HAD A TOWN HALL IN A
MINIMUM OF THREE YEARS, AT LEAST
WHERE WE'RE COUNTING, I'M TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT AROUND COVID, YOU
KNOW, SHE DOESN'T HAVE MEETINGS
WITH PEOPLE UNLESS THERE'S
CHECKS INVOLVED.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING
UNSCRIPTED.
WE HARDLY SEE HER IN ARIZONA.
SHE HAS CUT OFF EVERYBODY UNLESS
YOU ARE A BIG DONOR, SO, AGAIN,
I DON'T REALLY MATTER IN TERMS
OF HAVING TO SPEAK TO HER.
WHAT MATTERS IS SHE DOESN'T
SPEAK TO ARIZONIANS ANYMORE.
>> WHAT ARE YOU SAYING?
ARE YOU SAYING THIS IS JUST
ABOUT DONOR?
WHAT ARE YOU SAYING,
CONGRESSMAN?
>> THE VALUES OF ARIZONA DO NOT
MATCH WITH KYRSTEN SINEMA.
SHE CARRIES MORE ABOUT DONORS,
WHAT LOBBYISTS THINK, WHAT D.C.
THINKS BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T TALK
TO ARIZONIANS ANYMORE.
SHE DOESN'T FIGHT FOR US
ANYMORE.
SHE'S MORE LIKELY TO FIGHT FOR
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES AND
SENIORS THAT HAVE TO DRIVE TO
MEXICO TO GET CHEAP DRUG
APPLIES.
SHE'S MORE LIKELY TO FIGHT FOR
PRIVATE EQUITY MANAGERS, HEDGE
FUND MANAGERS TO MAKE SURE THEY
KEEP THEIR TAX CUT INSTEAD OF
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
KEEP THEIR TAX CREDIT.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE SAYING
THAT SHE IS -- IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE SAYING, CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG, THAT SHE'S BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR BY SPECIAL INTERESTS,
SHE'S IN IT FOR HERSELF AND THE
MONEY.
THAT'S WHY I SAID, WHAT ARE YOU
SAYING HERE?
>> I MEAN, EXACTLY THAT.
I DON'T THINK SHE'S IN IT FOR
THE MONEY FOR HERSELF.
I THINK SHE'S ACTUALLY A VERY
UPRIGHT PERSON WHEN IT COMES TO
HER PERSONAL FINANCES, BUT SHE
HAS SOLD OUT TO BIG, YOU KNOW,
INTERESTS TO DO THEIR BIDDING,
DO THE BIDDING OF EVERY DAY
ARIZONIANS.
>> SO LISTEN, I'M INTERESTED IN
WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY ABOUT THIS.
LAST WEEK AT DAVOS, SINEMA AND
JOE MANCHIN WERE ON A PANEL.
BLOCKED THE DECISION FOR HILL
BUSTER REFORM, AND HIGH FIVED
MANCHIN OVER THEIR EFFORTS TO
BLOCK IT.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHILE SOME WOULD SAY THAT
THERE WERE RELUCTANT FOLKS
WORKING IN CONGRESS IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS, I WOULD ACTUALLY SAY
THAT THAT WAS THE BASIS FOR THE
PRODUCTIVITY FOR SOME INCREDIBLE
ACHIEVEMENTS THAT MADE A
DIFFERENCE FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
>> WE STILL DON'T AGREE ON
GETTING RID OF THE FILIBUSTER,
CORRECT?
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
MOMENT, SIR?
>> WELL, THAT MOMENT WAS DURING
MLK WEEKEND WHICH IS A VERY
IMPORTANT WEEKEND IN ARIZONA
BECAUSE FOR MANY YEARS, WE DID
NOT ACTUALLY HAVE MARTIN LUTHER
KING WEEKEND, THE FACT THAT
SHE'S HIGH FIVING KILLING THE
FILIBUSTER ON MLK WEEKEND WHEN
SHE BEGAN HAS SKIPPED, AND
KILLING THE JOHN LEWIS VOTING
RIGHTS ACT, SOMEONE SHE CLAIMS
WAS HER FRIEND AND MENTOR, TELLS
YOU EVERYTHING ABOUT HER.
SHE DOESN'T REPRESENT ANYTHING.
SHE'S ABOUT HOLDING POWER FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE POWER.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT'S NOT
ABOUT TRYING TO WORK FOR THE
PEOPLE OF ARIZONA, IT'S TRYING
TO WORK FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE, YOU KNOW, INTERESTS,
WHETHER IT'S IN DAVOS OR WALL
STREET OR WHETHER IT'S IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> I HAVE TO ASK YOU ABOUT THIS.
WHAT'S GOING ON IN WASHINGTON?
I'M SURE YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
NEW HOUSE SPEAKER KEVIN McCARTHY
LAST NIGHT ANNOUNCING THAT HE IS
KEEPING OR KICKING TWO DEMOCRATS
OFF THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
OR KEEPING THEM OFF THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE AS WELL,
ADAM SCHIFF, ERIK SWALWELL, WHAT
DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> THIS IS JUST LIKE GRIEVANCE
POLITICS THAT McCARTHY IS
EXECUTING RIGHT NOW.
HE'S DOING IT TO BASICALLY KEEP
POWER BECAUSE I KNOW HIS MEMBERS
WANT HIM TO.
WE KNOW THAT ERIC SWALWELL AND
SCHIFF HAVE NOT DONE ANYTHING
INCORRECTLY.
THE FBI HAS STATED THAT SWALWELL
HAS BEEN CLEARED, DID NOT DO
ANYTHING AT ALL, INCLUDING, YOU
KNOW, PAUL RYAN AND DIFFERENT
SPEAKERS BEFORE McCARTHY WHO ALL
HAVE SAID, THERE'S BEEN NOTHING
INCORRECTLY.
SO AT ONE POINT THIS WILL
OBVIOUSLY CHANGE.
I THINK McCARTHY IS GOING TO
LOOK LIKE A FOOL, BUT HE'S ONLY
DOING THIS TO MAKE SURE HE CAN
HOLD POWER, NOT BECAUSE THESE
TWO ARE SOMEHOW A THREAT O
NATIONAL SECURITY.
WE NEED THEM ON THE COMMITTEES
BECAUSE THEY ARE BRIGHT.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
THEY HAVE THE CONTEXT, INSTEAD
HE'S DOING IT TO APPEASE THE
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENSES --.
>> CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS ARE A
BIG ISSUE, HAVE HAVE YOU MADE
SURE YOU DON'T HAVE?
>> I'M A MILLENNIAL, I DON'T DO
PAPER.
WHEN IT COMES TO CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, I READ IT IN A
SKIFF AND WHEN I LEAVE THAT
SKIFF, EVERYTHING I LEAVE IS
THERE.
SO I'M NOT CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH VICE PRESIDENT PENCE AND
THE PRESIDENT.
TO ME IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S VERY
INADVERTENT.
I'M GLAD THEY'RE COOPERATING.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SHOULD DO WHEN
YOU COME TO THIS POINT.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THEM TWO AND FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
WHAT HE IS DOING WAS ILLEGAL